all right the chapter for this week that
I have asked you to raid deals with the
Western Hemisphere with the new world in
the aftermath of the explorations of
Columbus and other Portuguese and
Spanish
Mariners I'm going to talk primarily
today about something that may at first
seem to be quite remote from this but in
fact I don't think it is because it
speaks to the very broad question of how
do we consider the eastern hemisphere
and the Western Hemisphere in world
history not that not speaking
specifically about the 16th century or
the 15th century or any other century
but just how do these two parts of the
world sort out when you are dealing with
this as an author of a textbook it often
comes down to the question of in what
chapter do you first mention the Western
Hemisphere civilizations some people say
you should mention them let us say by
chapter three or four because you have
many students of Hispanic heritage in
high schools and they will feel
diminished if their part of the world
doesn't get mentioned early on the same
argument of course is made for when
should you first mention Africa so that
is kind of a sociological argument based
on what are perhaps incorrect
assumptions about student anticipation
then there's the idea that you should
mention them that you should sort of
give the Western Hemisphere and the
pre-columbian era
as sort of a gestalt as a a big picture
where you start at the beginning you end
up with the incas of the Aztecs and you
do it all at once but then the problem
with that just put that early in the
book and the Incas and the Aztecs are in
power when the Spaniards come circa 1500
AD then the chapter goes too far forward
and it's jumping the gun chronologically
so then a third option is to put the
stuff the broad portrayal of the Western
Hemisphere just before the voyages of
exploration so that you're prepared for
what the Spaniards and the Portuguese
will find when they get there and then
there's a fourth option which is to
divide the coverage into two or three
different chunks which is something that
teachers don't like because they prefer
to deal with large you know for the
fairly homogeneous chunks as opposed to
more of a selected sorts short subjects
approach to things oh I'm going to adopt
a different approach today it's when
I've spent the last couple of months
working on which I hope will end up
being the seed of a short book and it
deals with the question of where did
civilization began and when did
civilization begin and what was
civilization when we approach this topic
in every world history textbook that I
know of we say that civilization began
in the river valleys of Egypt and
Mesopotamia and we often throw in the
Indus River Valley in what is now
southern Pakistan although some people
will put that in a in a separate chapter
but by and large civilization starts in
the
old-world river valleys and it starts
somewhere around 3500 BC although you
get a running start going back to say
5000 or so when you look at the late
Neolithic communities that emerge as
civilizations and you also point out
that the earliest city that has been
continuously inhabited in the old world
is Jericho at which for which you have a
time line that goes back to about 9000
BC so we've had civilization for a long
time in the old world in the new world
the earliest civilizations that are
thought of as full-fledged civilizations
that is to say ones that have intensive
agriculture urban development social
stratification division of labour luxury
artistic production of giant monumental
buildings and so forth
we usually identify these as the Olmecs
in southern Mexico and the trevean in
northern Peru the Olmecs you may well
have run into because they did some
really nifty sculpture the trevean you
probably have not run into but they're
about the same time the usually date
around 1500 BC in other words 2,000
years later than what you have in Egypt
and Mesopotamia where we're talking
about 3500 BC so nobody really questions
the idea that the earliest civilizations
are those in Egypt to Mesopotamia but of
course this comes from counting backward
from the present you're saying what are
the earliest civilizations relative to
today
and you go back and that's what you get
now if you turn it around and you say
when did modern humans Homo sapiens
sapiens the species we all belong to
when did they first become the resident
population in different parts of the
world then we get a very different story
homo sapiens sapiens is thought to come
into being say fifty to sixty thousand
years ago in East Africa sort of parts
of what today it would be Ethiopia and
Somalia that's let's let's just say
fifty thousand years ago because it's
such a nice round number
modern humans left Africa this is during
an ice age although that wasn't a big
deal for Africa there were no glaciers
or anything but they left Africa and
they arrived in Australia by forty
thousand years ago so it took ten
thousand years for them to get from East
Africa to Australia and about the same
amount of time for them to get to Europe
although the distance between Europe and
East Africa is only about you know maybe
20% of the distance between asked for
between East Africa and Australia so
those who ended up in Australia really
scampered they they moved along and they
ended up in Australia and those in
Europe well just took up a long time to
find their way you know maps or anything
like that but there should be some
exploits explanations work but we don't
care about that because we're talking
about 40,000 years ago there were modern
humans in Egypt and Mesopotamia now when
it comes to southern Mexico and Peru
there's no there's virtually no
scientific opinion that maintains that
modern humans arrived in southern Mexico
or Peru more than 15,000 years ago so in
other words 40,000 years ago in the old
world in in the areas that become
civilized first and fifteen thousand
years ago being generous in the areas to
become civilized in the new world so now
you you have dates to count forward from
you can say how long did it take to go
from let me make this 40,000 plus to
round it off a little
how do long to take to go from the first
modern humans in the Middle East and
Egypt to the first urban site that we
know of
well thirty one thousand years the first
urban site in the new world was the site
of Corral on the Peruvian coast when I
got there in I get there in Peru and
fifteen thousand let's say they have a
city by 2600 BC so here we have an
elapsed time 31 thousand years my math
is wrong correctly and here we have an
elapsed time of let's say twelve
thousand four hundred years
then we have full-fledged civilization
comes along eleven hundred years later
and here full-fledged
civilization comes along fifty five
hundred years later and you look at it
counting forward and you say what is
taking those people in the old world so
damn long to create civilization the the
earliest civilizations are in the old
world but the most precocious
civilizations are in the new world now
no one ever talks about this I haven't
found anyone who's willing to even
debate it and yet nobody disagrees on
the numbers you can disagree on the
question of what is the civilization but
even there most of the old world
archaeologists are willing to grant they
did have civilizations in the new world
and that they're roughly in the
timetable that that has suggested so
whatever was happening in the new world
was just going much much much faster
than whatever was happening in the old
world now in the old world
we have archaeology it was produced a
very elaborate and impressive story you
have a Neolithic Revolution that comes
sometime around 10,000 BC or so when
little bitty sharp stones that are found
on sites are evidence that they put the
stones in a wooden frame and used this
sickle with sharp stones to cut down the
straws in wild and fields of wild grain
then we have evidence that wheat and
barley became domestic crops at roughly
the that time
and we can tell what mutations were
necessary particularly for wheat just
one mutation in order to get I'll go
from wild wheat to to domestic wheat
then you have further mutations after
that so we get the Neolithic stone tools
then we get the evidence of grain
cultivation domestication then we get
roughly simultaneously the evidence that
sheep and goats and cows are becoming
domestic and so we have the invention of
farming and herding this great leap
forward on the basis of which after only
a few thousand more years from ten
thousand to thirty five hundred after
only a few thousand more years this
ripens into civilization this is
considered the primary story of the
extraordinary capability of our species
this is what we did we had powers of
innovation and creativity that were so
great that we're able to go from
Paleolithic stone tools that were little
more than chunks of rock we picked up
you know around the campsite to
full-fledged
urban civilization in a matter of what
you know only thirty six thousand five
hundred years now some people have
questioned that they said you know what
were people doing for thirty five
thousand years you know sitting on their
thumbs I mean what if we were so
creative and innovative why did it take
so long and this is what is called
there's an English
archaeologists named Colin Renfrew and
he has called this the the sapient
paradox if sapiens Homo sapiens sapiens
sapiens meaning knowing things if if the
humans that came into being at the time
we think our species originated and
we've had no profound changes in our
mental capacities since that time if
they came into being fifty thousand
years ago then their capability
conceptually to create civilization must
have been their latent for thirty forty
thousand years before it dawned on them
to say wheat
what we need is to eat this wheat and
domesticate it and get that sheep over
here because we're going to eat it too
the sapient paradox was that it took so
long
the paradox you know how you'll have the
innate ability to create civilization
and yet you can't seem to pull the
trigger for such a very long time that's
the safety and parents now the problem
with it is of course is that in southern
Mexico and Peru they pulled the trigger
so much earlier so much faster the
people who came in 15,000 BC by the
common consensus of pretty much all
archaeologists had no greater knowledge
of tools or cultural attainments than
the people who showed up in the Middle
East forty thousand years ago in other
words there was no headstart you look at
the earliest stone tools that you have
in the Western Hemisphere say the Clovis
culture of the Southwest United States
and those stone tools
look just about like the same stone
tools for the same period in Europe in
addition DNA analysis has pretty much
confirmed that the paleo-indians that is
to say the first human modern human
inhabitants of the Western Hemisphere
were descended genetically from people
who lived in northeastern Asia and
Siberia and whose relatives are still
living there and these relatives are
people like the chuck cheese and the
quarry ax neither a household name when
chatting on the subject of civilization
because Northeast Asia endeavor does
make a move to civilization so it's very
hard to claim that the people who came
the new world had a head start so
instead you have the the problem of how
did they get to civilization so fast and
how did the people in the old world take
so much time to get to the same stage
even though in the old world they got
there earlier in pure chronological
terms there is a
no no absolute way of answering this but
let me start by suggesting some things
first of all when you take the original
Homo sapiens sapiens in East Africa
they are the descendants of earlier
species of homonyms going back to
Australia australopith occurs that had
all lived in Eastern Africa it is
reasonable to assume that in their home
territory there were some animals that
really liked to eat people because
humans are not at the top of the food
chain we don't have any teeth we don't
have any claws worth talking about until
we figured out how to throw stones we
couldn't kill big animals but we were
pretty easy prey if somebody wanted to
eat one of us what were we going to do
say actually I'm equipped with speech so
I can tell you do not do not attack me
mr. lion because I'm a human I'm
equipped with speech and I can talk you
to death now so you have to assume that
as in virtually every other situation in
the world you had a coevolution of
predator species and prey species that's
somebody eight people and probably kept
the population in check because that's
what we find in prey predator
relationships around the globe is that
you have coevolution of species in which
the number of predators and the number
of prey are in a kind of balance to many
of the prey get eaten
the Predators die because their food is
gone not enough of them get eaten then
you get more predators being big borne
so somebody was eating people we don't
have any evidence of who that is
could have been de Lions out on the
savanna if I were a lion and I could
bring down a giraffe or an okapi or an
eland or something
I wouldn't go after a human it's
well maybe appetizer size meal but it's
it's not the sort of thing I'm going to
do as a lion the likelihood in my view
and the view of these one anthropologist
is real quickly on to this is that
people were eaten by hyenas the
anthropologist who's written about this
has argued that hyenas uniquely among
the e staff of the native East African
predators prefer to have their dens
where people live instead of being a
predator that stays away from people the
hyenas like to stay where the people are
the hyenas are nocturnal so they stay in
a den during the day and at night they
come out and they eat the boys and girls
and the oldsters that they can get their
their teeth on Plus hyenas are
unbelievably ferocious I have the
pleasure of visiting hyena research
facility at Berkeley a couple of years
ago and they're just terribly ferocious
animals and one thing that's very
special about them is that when they eat
you they eat the bones they just crunch
up the whole thing so they're their
faeces are bright white because they are
excreting the calcium of all the bones
they chewed up and no I saw it you know
they give a you know the neck bone of a
pig push it through the slot and this
hyena comes and simply crunches it up
and eats the whole thing particularly
the female because the females dominate
and the poor meant that they feed the
female first and then they try and give
something to the male somewhere else so
he won't be left out because the females
will steal the food from the male's
they're terribly ferocious animals okay
maybe their reign is maybe not but if
you move out of the territory where you
have a natural predator you're going to
live longer because the people the
Predators into whose territory you're
removing
have co-evolved with other species not
with you in particular so you go into
India and you find well Tigers will eat
humans but frankly they prefer to eat a
you know an ill guy or a water buffalo
or something that's what they grew up
with humans are sort of the new prey on
the block so so the reason there are
maybe that the reason they're so few
hominin remains in East Africa is that
most of the people were chewed up of the
heinous and left as little deposits of
hyena dropping now humans could not
easily move out of this environment so
long as they were living on plants the
problem is that any species that is
primarily herbivorous knows what plants
they can eat and what can't plants they
can't they acquire this you know
essentially through cultural processes
over generations most plants you cannot
eat they you either cannot digest it or
it will poison you or it tastes terrible
so it's a fairly small number of species
of plants in any environment can be
eaten so if you move out of your native
habitat you have the problem that you're
going into an area of where there are
new plants and you don't know which ones
you can eat that some might look like
the old plants but then you you you eat
it and you die and you say oh that was a
mistake
and there must have been a lot of
experiment like that you know you know
do you remember so-and-so he ate that
he's dead so now we know we don't eat
that but but that takes a long time to
learn so when you move out of your home
environment
it's very important to be a carnivore
because for all intents and purposes all
flesh is edible so it is the it is tool
making the ability to acquire meat and
to prefer meat that precedes the moving
of humans Out of Africa now we define
that primarily as hunting and we support
this because we collect stones that have
been chipped into hand axes or spear
points or something and we say this is
what they hunted with but the likelihood
is that it wasn't the hunting that led
people out but rather the fishing when
you look at people going from East
Africa to Australia far more rapidly
than they were able to go from East
Africa to France how did they get to
Australia so fast and the answer almost
certainly is that they followed the
coastline at that time the sea level was
about 400 feet lower than it is now as a
result you could go from East Africa all
the way to Borneo and only have to cross
one body of salt water there's a very
narrow strait between Yemen and Africa
that is still there it's bigger now and
you would have to cross that but
otherwise you could simply walk along
the coast from Somalia to Borneo without
having to cross the nice hot water then
when he got to Borneo you would have to
cross another body of water in order to
get to Australia so certainly there was
some water that was crossed but at that
time Southeast Asia was a subcontinent
all the islands of Indonesia the
Philippines they're all
connected by dry land it was just a
subcontinent and Australia and New
Guinea were a whole continent if humans
followed the coastline followed the fish
all the way to Australia it would leave
virtually no trace because once the ice
age ended and the sea level level rose
again the whole coastal areas were
flooded so any archaeological remains
are now underwater for example the
entire Persian Gulf was dry land at that
time and archaeologists now assume that
early human habitation in that area is
under water it's in the Persian Gulf
so we have very hard time proving that
that was the way people traveled and yet
there is a new scientific technique that
has been adopted to test this sort of
hypothesis this has to do with the
analysis of an isotope of two isotopes
of nitrogen isotope 14 an isotope 15
nitrogen only has two stable isotopes
and so nitrogen 14 and nitrogen 15 show
up together in the atmosphere they show
up together in plants that are capable
of binding nitrogen or bacteria that are
capable of binding nitrogen that is say
taking nitrogen out of the air or out of
the soil and turning them into plant
tissues animals cannot directly buy
nitrogen although maybe some bacteria in
an animal could but by and large this is
what plants do is that they take
nitrogen out of the atmosphere and
whatever nitrogen ends up in human
tissues comes from ultimately from
eating plants
the ratio between nitrogen 14 and
nitrogen 15 in a given area is
considered to be pretty much a constant
now to say the ratio and the atmosphere
whether it's always been a constant is
hard to tell but it's generally assumed
that this is been a constant component
of air throughout geological times when
a plant takes in nitrogen then it takes
in the two forms nitrogen 50 or nitrogen
14 animals for reasons that have still
not been finally determined animals seem
to excrete more nitrogen 14 than
nitrogen 15 that means that in a given
area if you measure the nitrogen 15 in
plants from the area whether to their
plants today or archaeologically you can
say let us say the plants have a level
of 6 then you say well but the cows have
a level of 11 because they retain more
nitrogen 15 than the plants do then you
look at the lions that eat the cows and
you say well that's the next in a food
chain each level it's called a trophic
level so that cows eat plants lions eat
cows those are different trophic levels
autotrophic refers to from a Greek root
meaning food
so then you'll find that if the if the
plants were six and the cows were eleven
the Lions will be 14 they'll have more
nitrogen 15 than the cows who in turn
will have more nitrogen 15 than the
plants if you are in a marine
environment or a freshwater environment
you have many more trophic levels than
you have in a terrestrial environment
that is to say there are big fish eat
smaller fish which eat smaller fish with
each which he meets fuller at smaller
fish all the way down to the bottom
where you have phytoplankton or
something like that being consumed so it
turns out that the highest levels of
nitrogen 15 are in the fish particularly
in those fish that are at the top of the
food chain the same fish for example
that accumulate mercury for exactly the
same reasons that they're the at the top
of the trophic tree so let us say you
take from an archeological site you take
some sheep bones let's say domestic
sheep you'll figure humans eat the Sheep
and then you take some human bones and
you compare with the nitrogen levels do
the humans have the same nitrogen level
as the Sheep probably not there'll be a
little more cuz there they're eating the
sheep but they're also eating vegetables
but if they have a lot more nitrogen it
means they're eating a lot of fish and
what has been found in in different
areas though this is still a fairly new
field of archaeology is that in in
regions where we have always thought
that herd animals were the were the
primary resource for humans who were
herders and hunters you'd say you know
let's say Ukraine or Romania
back between 4 and 5000 BC if you look
at the nitrogen levels you'll find out
that even though the people living there
were herders and even though they had
hunting and they had tools for all this
it appears that over 50% of all of their
protein came from eating fish it was the
rivers that flowed into the Black Sea
like the Danube and the pruth and the
bug and the nester and the Knepper and
the whole the DOM whole crowd of rivers
this is where people were getting their
food and why well it's awful lot easier
to catch a fish than to catch an
antelope the for one thing the fish tend
to come to you you know you're standing
there by the stream fish swims by the
envelope run away from you you have to
chase the antelope
if Bears can live on salmon simply going
along whoo I got a salmon why couldn't
people just go whoo look yeah blue fish
look lionfish you know so we don't know
but it seems likely that fishes is the
clue now this helps understand why
people who walked all the way across
from East Africa over a period of ten
thousand years to Australia also went up
the coast of Asia to Siberia and crossed
over into Alaska somewhere say between
14 and 16 thousand years ago because
they're following the coast and cold
waters have abundant fish resources so
they probably were not crossing from
Siberia to Alaska chasing reindeer or
hunting for seals they're probably
following the fish along the coast and
once they got to North America well hey
just go down the Pacific Coast pretty
soon you're in prime salmon territory
Alaska salmon
no state of Washington salmon I presume
the Canadians have salmon too but you
never hear about it then you get down
farther you know the you know san
diego's tuna fishing industry and
finally you get down to the world's most
abundant fishery which is the coast of
Peru and southern Mexico the Pacific
coast of southern Mexico is not quite as
well endowed as a coast of Peru
but this is the great fishery and that
is where people ended up despite the
fact that the land on the coast of Peru
was an extremely dry desert so I this
theory people were more interested in
eating the fish so some of them are
going inland and hunting other animals
certainly you know got to catch those
mammoths and wooly rhinoceri if I and so
on
but a lot of people were getting fish
and then after they had established
themselves then they looked around for
plants to eat all right
why did people do this the fundamental
assumption of the theory that I'm
presenting here is that people and by
people I mean primarily men don't like
to be around other people very much that
you know they say you know I'd like to
go out in the woods we're getting a
sailboat
go sailing all right have a summer place
or you know maybe just you know live in
a you know in a cargo container or
something I mean piano box I mean I I
just don't like people very much
there's scarcely a man alive I think who
has not thought I would like to get away
from all these people and go out and
simply be a man now I when I taught a
course on domestic animals I'd ID a
student students how would you kill an
animal if you didn't have any thing but
your bare hands you'd haven't invented
any stone tools yet and and the football
players who really like the course it's
well I I grabbed it by the horns watch
the neck like this but its neck and I'd
say okay now you've you've broken the
neck of this poor sad beast how do you
get inside if you don't have anything to
cut with well that would always be a
puzzle because you know leather is tough
to get through so then we'd end up
talking about eating eyeballs and
testicles and other soft parts and the
discussion deteriorated from there but
the but the thing is that
it appears that Homo sapiens sapiens as
a species contains one gender that
prefers to to go off to new territory
rather than stay home and fight with the
neighbors the dispersal of humans around
the world
I think cannot be explained in any other
way somebody wanted to go someplace new
and of course it means that there were
people who saw really cool things for
the first time not for the first time of
anyone in their hometown the first time
of any human at all they they got that
it was adventure so they they roamed far
afield they did not stay home and fight
over their territory some did probably
but enough did not that you have these
adventurers going everywhere other words
I'm taking a stand against the Hobbesian
notion of the war of all against all
where you have my bit of land and you
have your a bit of land and let's fight
and I'll take your land you take my land
now the current I think they spread out
how else can we account for them
appearing every place why is that
important that's important when you look
at this terribly unequal timetable
if you look at a world well I mean first
of all let me just make a remark sort of
by the side which is something I lecture
on last year which is that the early
civilizations in the old world in the
river valleys of Egypt Mesopotamia
Pakistan and a bit later in China those
river valleys are all north of the
Tropic of Cancer they are in what is
technically called the temperate zone
even though they're very hot at least
the non Chinese ones the the tropical
zone between the Tropic of Cancer and
the Tropic of Capricorn does not have
any early old world civilizations
thinkers going back to ancient Greece
and Iran thought that it was simply too
hot down in the tropics to have
civilization and by and large this has
been sort of tacitly echoed by later
historians if you look at the western
hemisphere at the new world all of the
early civilizations are in the tropics
from peru up to mexico you're dealing
with the area between the Tropic of
Cancer and the Tropic of Capricorn these
are all tropical civilizations
why would the single species to which we
all belong really like the tropics in
one hemisphere and you know in order to
make it there civilizational home
whereas in the other hemisphere they
they avoid the tropics seemingly one of
the recent general historians whose
attempted to explain why the West is
ahead of the rest of the world
Ian Morris has solved this by inventing
the phrase the lucky latitudes says the
lucky latitude the lucky latitudes in
the old world were say between 22 and 40
degrees north latitude
while the lucky latitudes and the
Western Hemisphere we're between I say
22 south latitude and 22 north latitude
they're the lucky latitude I I don't
like to refer to a senior colleague in
another university as being stupid but
but this really is not a constructive
way to approach things is to say well
this is the way it was so let's simply
say it was just luck if you look at the
tropics in the new world on a map and
you don't need a map just to just keep
in your head the one thing you find is
that the space in the new world tropics
is physically the most restricted space
anywhere on the globe particularly if
you assume a sea level that was much
lower than it is now so that Southeast
Asia was all dry land as opposed to
divided up into the Malay Peninsula and
and the islands of South of Southeast
Asia
this was the narrowest area southern
Mexico through Central America and then
down the Peruvian coast
between the Pacific Ocean and the Andes
and that's so that's a very narrow band
of territory if you look at the tropical
areas in the old world what do you find
is they're enormous ly broad to go from
Senegal across to East Africa then you
know you hop skip and jump over the
strait to Yemen you go across Arabia
southern Iran India down to Southeast
Asia there is no limit on where you can
go the space of the afro-eurasian
eastern hemisphere landmass is enormous
and the Australian landmass is is very
substantial particularly if you compare
it to Peru or to Panama or Guatemala
these are very narrow spaces so this
raises the question as to whether the
triggering factor in the birth of
civilization was spatial did the
narrowness of space the disappearance of
new land to disperse into force people
into patterns of cooperation and
conflict that gave rise to settled life
agriculture civilization and so forth
this would explain what happened in
these very precocious civilizational
developments in the New World
how would it do for the old world well
in the old world you know basically
the period of civilizational development
is between 5,000 3,500 BC where you have
Egypt and Mesopotamia and the Indus
Valley becoming the seedbeds for
civilizations that happens to coincide
with a period of dramatic desiccation of
the climate these areas dried up in an
extraordinary fashion starting around
5,000 BC in other words if you go back
to 6000 BC this is a the Sahara Desert
was a big grassy plain with mountains
and wild animals we have rock carvings
from the middle of Sahara Desert that
show the big game that was once hunted
in the central Sahara pictures of
elephants pictures of hippopotamus
pictures of crocodiles the Sahara was
one of the really nice parts of the
world and a huge rivers running through
it you can fly over the Sahara now and
see these old river valleys full of sand
by 2500 BC there was no water left in
the Sahara Desert completely dried up it
had reached by 2500 BC it had reached
the level of dryness than of house today
and I tell you there's say if you've
been to the American Southwest and you
see you think you've seen a desert go to
the Sahara and see what a real desert is
like it is unbelievably barren I
remember thinking oh that powder it's so
fine is it really sand so I said well
I'll just damp with my finger put some
light oh it's sand
now I have sand in my mouth why what a
stupid thing to do and how do I get this
thing outta my mouth but but really in
the Sahara this hand is often like
talcum powder it is so fine and hangs in
the air and it's just
nothing like it in in the deserts were
more familiar with in this country
Arabia dried up during this time the
Middle East dried up in general after
all Iraq and Syria are sort of the
northern extensions of the Arabian
Peninsula southern Pakistan the province
of Sindh dried up at this time Northwest
India of the Rajasthan desert the Rann
of Kutch area they dried up at this time
as these areas dried up all of which had
people living in them there was the
there was less and less game to hunt
less and less possibility of foraging
for plants because the plants were dying
out what you had were river valleys that
became functional isthmus you had
instead of in say Panama if you go to
the West you're in the Pacific Ocean you
go to the East you're in the Caribbean
Sea in Egypt if you go to the West
you're in the desert if you go to the
East you're in the desert you can't live
in either neither place whether it's a
desert or whether it is an ocean you are
locked into that River Valley so the
what happens in the old world is that
the people are there earlier but the
Isthmus azar not and it's the appearance
of the Isthmus --is that triggers the
increase in density
that generates patterns of cooperation
and conflict that lead on to
civilization it is likely that another
attraction of these big river valleys
was that they were full of fish because
you have in the desert they're just
fewer and fewer animals to hunt but the
river valleys had fish since we have not
had nitrogen 15 analyses of bone
collagen from these areas early on I
don't have any actual date on this this
is just a surmise on my part okay so
that is the isthmus theory of
civilization that says that in world
history
we should from the very beginning talk
about humans and space how did the globe
come to be inhabited and what kinds of
opportunities or constraints came about
in many parts of the world as population
density increased people domesticated
the local plants but did not necessarily
take the next step of rising to
civilization because we are so fixated
on the the Neolithic Revolution and
those liddie little bitty sharp stones
we tend not to pay much attention to
plants other than grain plants so if you
say ten thousand years ago
wheat and barley are being grown in in
southern Turkey on the the hilly flanks
of the Taurus Mountains you say ah
that's where civilization is going to
begin but ten thousand years ago in New
Guinea remains from a site known as the
kook swamp have shown that taro root
bananas and sweet potatoes we're all
being grown artificially uncultivated
plots and ban iakh and certain other
root crops potatoes go back to similar
early roots we have tended not to pay
attention to crops that are not grain
crops because those are not the ones
that led to Egypt and Mesopotamia on the
other hand the idea that grain crops are
better than other crops really isn't
very supportable I just mentioned the
book by Ian Morris in one section
it's called fly the West's ahead dot dot
dot for now and and he says well of the
54 grasses that have the largest seeds
something like thirty five of them are
found in the middle east of which some
of them like wheat and barley and rye
become cultivated plants and he says and
grains are the most important food crop
around the world
you know wheat barley corn rice and
sorghum so well there was no rice in the
Middle East
that's from India there was certainly
you know corn in the Middle East that's
from Mexico
sorghum comes from either China or
Africa there's some debate on sorghum
and nobody eats barley anymore and what
I mean short you know beef barley soup
okay hazel yeah but fortunately we drink
beer and so we have some use for barley
but by and large people long time ago
quit drinking it quit eating barley
because they didn't like it very much so
of those great grain crops from the
Fertile Crescent only one of them really
makes it down to modern times as a key
crop in that sweet in terms of acreage
fleet is not necessarily the most
abundant crop in the United States both
corn and soybeans have more acreage than
wheat so I think we have vastly over
played the importance of wheat and
barley because we're the descendants of
the people who started out eating wheat
and barley and indeed we're the
descendants of civilized people we have
to surely honor civilization in that
respect now
yeah you have to understand that wheat
and barley were terribly non-nutritious
everybody agrees that civilization
coincides with a substantial decline in
the health of the people who were eating
these first domesticated crops
archaeologically one of the things one
of the markers you have if you find a
human skull you see whether there are
any cavities and the teeth because the
foragers the hunters and gatherers never
have cavities but if you ate grain as
your primary staple you develop cavities
the size of humans was smaller with
civilization the fact of the matter is
that civilization was not good for most
people in health terms for the top two
percent among whom fortunately everyone
at Columbia is now numbered for the top
two percent civilization was really
really really really good and led to
wonderful things but the fact matter is
that most people who live in civilized
societies today do not live very good
lives and they haven't lived good lives
for the last eight thousand years five
thousand years all right so there's a
question as to whether is the reason I'm
stressing this and perhaps exaggerating
it that's a certainly exaggerating it is
that the the assumption when people
write about civilization is that
civilization was really a great
discovery a big leap forward humans
after this long sapient paradox of
twiddling their thumbs suddenly they got
their act together and create a
civilization and everything has been
wonderful ever since but if you switch
to the isthmus theory then you say
civilization comes about not because
it's a huge creative leap forward
to be universally applauded but because
it's a necessity caused by the
disappearance of Laban from a space to
live and that's reason it occurs more
precociously in the new world tropics
where space is the most limited and in
only a rather dilatory fashion in the
old world temperate zone when the Fluke
of climate change caused these huge
deserts to open up and force people into
into greater densities of a population
one final piece of this is that the old
world got the domestic animals this is
taken particularly by Jared Diamond as
being an example of really good luck
because only by different people's
counts only 14 or 20 species of animals
are capable of being domesticated and
the key ones the cattle the sheep the
goats the pigs lived in the Middle East
and therefore this was a huge advantage
to them but the problem here is that
when the countryside was drying up these
wild animals where were they going to
get their food because their their food
resources we're disappearing the plants
were all dying the lakes streams we're
all drying up where were they going to
go they're going to go into the river
valleys or other places where you still
have some rainfall what are they going
to eat they're gonna eat grass which is
but you know usually they'll select
grass on the menu who is growing grass
people are growing grass so in fact the
humans who devised this notion of using
wheat and barley as staple crops were in
competition with the animals because
those animals were inclined to eat the
crops that the humans were growing
there's a direct competition what do you
do when you're in competition with a
with an animal species if you're a human
you can do one of three things you can
kill all of them and that's always a
human favorite to kill off the competing
species or you can take the species and
move them somewhere else away from your
crops this is what we call pastoral
nomadism where you have
should go out and heard the animals and
keep them away from the wheat and barley
fields or you can domesticate them which
means that you're keeping some of them
captive different theories on why
they're kept captive my own theory is
that it was for purposes of religious
sacrifice rather than as a basic meat
supply but other people will disagree on
that but the one thing that there is
agreement on is that the animals that
were kept captive are particularly those
from the bovine family are way smaller
than the wild examples of the same
species the reason is that the humans
who captured them and held them in pens
fed them straw but did not feed them
grain because they wanted to grain
themselves so these first domestic
animals were malnourished and were kept
away from the fields by being penned up
in the new world tropics there were no
competing animals there were you know if
you were growing manioc or potatoes or
beans or squash you weren't worrying
about a herd of cows coming in and
eating everything you had because you
didn't have any large animals that were
competing for you another reason you can
move your civilization ahead faster
another consideration here is that some
of the most virulent diseases that
humans have ever had have come about by
the transfer of pathogens from domestic
animals that they live with to human
populations you know we think of swine
flu an avian flu but tuberculosis comes
originally from kyle's apparently
smallpox probably from cows you have to
assume
that those people who started living
with these animals in some communities
all died
now when the Europeans came to the new
world and brought with them diseases
like measles and smallpox and implements
a ridiculous and so forth almost
everyone in the new world died you know
say 70 to 90% of the population and
people I say it was because they didn't
they didn't grow up with the animals and
therefore these diseases that have begun
by cohabiting with animals they were not
they had not developed a resistance to
but you have to assume the little people
in the old world were not born with this
resistance but that there were periods
when you had whole societies that
probably died from diseases they caught
from there from their animals until they
developed an immunity or a strong enough
resistance to to carry on so neither the
wheat and barley availability nor the
access to animals help very much in
trying to explain the the difference
between old-world
civilization new world civilization
instead of tweetIn barley and sheep
goats and cattle hastening the process
of civilization it appears that the
process of civilization was not very
hasty
whereas in areas that did not have those
grains and did not have the animals that
is where the process of civilization
went in a speedy fashion
if we're dealing here with essentially
the interaction of two very simple
things one is an innate desire or
inclination of of human males to
disperse rather than than face crowding
and conflict and on the other hand the
consequences of the disappearance of
space to disperse to if you say that the
disappearance of space triggers the
cultural and economic developments that
lead to civilization and that had
happened you know vastly faster in the
new world than in the old world even
though it happened earlier in the old
world then you're then you're edging
into an area that is around there
interesting because you're suggesting
that that a primary driver of human life
on the planet
was crowding
that so long as you had new space to
move into hominins did just find a very
low density levels and led comparatively
healthful lives that didn't require a
whole lot of work to maintain their
themselves and had plenty of time to
left left over to you know sing songs
and vent myths you know we've string
figures whatever but it was only when
the space ran out but if that's the case
then what happens when you start to
measure crowding in a more formal way in
other words if the density for hunters
and gatherers is let us say
hypothetically one per square mile a
figure that's often used by people who
are studying foraging communities then
you have a a non coastal community that
has say 150 people living at it and it's
occupying a an area with a radius of
somewhat less than 10 miles so in the
course of the year they go around and
they collect this that the other thing
and they kill this that the other thing
one person square per square mile works
pretty well and your population doesn't
grow because the hain is there always
lurking around to eat up your kids
but if crowding then triggers these
other things that crowding may be moving
from let's say one person per square
mile to 50 per square mile maybe that's
enough to get you to start cultivating
your own bananas and then maybe you go
to 200 per square mile or 2,000 per
square mile where God knows what the
density is of the Upper West Side of
Manhattan thousands per square mile
does crowding over the long term in
human history create a gradient along
which developments in human society and
interaction between human societies
along which gradient you can measure
things people have looked at this on a
piecemeal basis from time to time
in other words historical demography
will get into the issue of where were
the biggest cities in the world and how
big were they at a given point in time
one of the most influential demographers
for Europe man named Josiah Russell
wrote a book on late ancient and
medieval populations in which he he
measured densities based on tax records
and things like that and found out that
the density of population in medieval
France for example or England was way
below the density of population in
Renaissance Italy or in Flanders during
the period of the Northern Renaissance
in other words when you had concentrated
populations you also often had the
flourishing of culture when you had
dispersed populations not a whole lot
happened you know Toulouse in the 12th
century was a pretty quiet town
whereas Pisa was beginning to move
if you compare these densities on
cross-continental basis over time you
might raise a question of does the are
the driving impulses of human history
the product of ingenuity invention
scientific or spiritual thought or are
they more mechanistic things that are
triggered by changes in density of
population one thing to keep in mind
here is that when the density goes down
then you would expect a regression well
of course this is coming back just
briefly to the topic of today's chapter
this is of course what happens in the
new world
the Europeans come in they encounter
urban societies of great sophistication
although not very impressive armament
they spread diseases that kill 90
percent of the population and then this
the story thereafter becomes the story
of what the Europeans do or the story of
what the Africans
of the Europeans bring in do but the
story of what the native populations new
world do is dropped it's dropped because
well there was no aftermath to the
Aztecs
there was no aftermath to the Incas they
their civilizations did not have what it
took to grow and prosper and challenge
why didn't they have what it took
because everybody was dead once your
population drops I mean we're talking
here people are estimating that
Oh Mexico goes from 34 million down to
to a couple of million
you know the percentages and the hard
numbers are difficult to find any
consensus on but the the level of
population regression is absolutely
phenomenal so what we do is that we we
say Europeans conquered the local
civilizations and that was the end of
that without really taking into account
the fact that with the disappearance of
most of the population the possibility
of continuous had been had been erased
so you can only speculate just about the
continued in spite of bin but then you
have to compound it with two things one
the desire of the Europeans to create a
life like the Hanna in Europe and
secondly the act of desire the Europeans
to destroy what they encounter don't
take an example there is a plant called
amaranth it grows in Mexico was used as
a food grain under the Aztecs it was a
popular food grain if you look up
comparative nutritional value it is a
head of wheat on virtually every index
and it's supposedly tastes real good the
Aztecs would have one month of the year
in which everybody ate amaranth because
it was sacred to the God who eats he
locally who is there no a crucial God
and at the end of the month they would
have a big fu effigy of that guy and
they break it into pieces and was made
out of amaranth seeds breaking into
pieces everyone to eat a bit of the God
where do we ever hear about eat health
eating God's I'm and
and then you would have the climax of
this month of celebration would be human
sacrifice and so the Spaniards came and
they said this God is a demon
we will prohibit the growing of amaranth
so that today as amaranth is beginning
to be rediscovered from wild stock still
in Mexico the fact that this had the
potential to be one of the great world
food crops was lost because the
Spaniards decided it was demonic so what
I'm talking about really is if you saw
the movie Avatar
and you combined it with the movie
Contagion so that the the beastly humans
come to a planet can only see what they
want impose themselves upon the local
people and then when the local people
try and fight back they all die that is
kind of the story of this chapter but
because we are the descendants of those
Europeans not all of us but many of us
we celebrate them and we say look at
what they did they brought cows so now
we have cows and they brought wheat so
we can have you know beef shall water
mow with pizza no we can eat these
things that humans want to eat and then
you go to Mexico and you find that well
actually thank you fish tacos on corn
tortillas are just fine it the the the
hubris the assumption of the superiority
of Western civilization you cannot
disown it because in fact Western
civilization ended up on top but you can
certainly ask that the story be told in
a way that is more sensitive
to the actual historical situation and
the way to do that is to from the very
beginning of your world history course
single out the precociousness of the
Western Hemisphere societies in the
building of civilization and say they
were not slow they were not behind in
fact they scampered along a lot faster
than those those Egyptians and those
Sumerians so that is the the end of
today's sermon